graphs graphs what a graphs we've looked
at some before okay it's a simple idea
right you start with something like this
we call this this equation call it like
a rule it's a rule that binds together
two numbers summarize and son X's right
you can draw up a table of values but
what it'll look like if you draw up a
whole bunch of these values he's putting
together and it looks like this okay so
this this part down here this is the
graph of this particular rule or
equation okay so you've got this is
actually worth writing down you've got a
rule or equation right and this is all
algebra stuff algebraic and it has this
equivalent in visual terms this is the
graph now because they're so closely
related you can use them in relation to
each other you can solve things about
this from this for instance I know that
this value in here is 1 I get that from
up here you can go in the other
direction as well you can use things
about this to solve things here and
we're gonna I'm going to show you how
that works over the next couple of weeks
okay now here's the important um the
metaphor that I have in my head okay
there's this formal algebraic thing and
it is a picture that's what it looks
like okay in my head the metaphor I
compare this to is that a ruler equation
it's a little bit like a sheet of music
now I can't reuse it I should be able to
because I did like preliminary great
piano so once upon a time there's all
this now okay yeah but I'll get onto
that and second um music right it's got
like all these symbols on it and it's
gone numbers even a lot right but what
that's intended to do is you're meant to
hear it right you play the music so you
you perceive it through that sort of
sense okay well going from this to the
actual music itself right that's making
this formal like written thing it's
making it audible okay well this is
making
this formal written thing into something
visible right okay so it's the same kind
of transition that's what we're doing
we're trying to be able to sense it
through the procedure through the senses
that we have okay so where are we going
to start is with the grasses already
known namely the linear ones so that's
why as Sapir actually asked we're going
to talk a bit a bit about great yet talk
about inter sets all those kinds of
things okay just to keep you in the
picture where we're going to go from
there is that linear graphs I'm not
doing the five graphs don't have to be
straight lines there are lots of other
ones there there are things called on
parabolas they're an interesting shape
we will explore yeah there are other
shapes called exponential graphs we'll
talk about those later on when there are
sir because we're not going to deal with
them under this topic yet though okay
the last one after this hold on revelers
attention oh yeah hyperbolas so they all
have cool funky names they are all
different kinds of shapes and we're
gonna explore the algebra and then how
it leads to a picture right just like
here's the way I think about it right
see you have these different kinds of
pictures it's a little bit like thinking
will have different genres of music
right you got classical you pot you got
your dubstep on and on and on and they
all sound different well these are like
how they look different off of different
kinds of rules any questions different
algebra questions yes that's exactly
right and we will look at that in due
time okay next week is actually going
into it